hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar titled the diagnostic and
clinical impact of
sars cov2 variants i'm susie valdez of
labruz and i will be your moderator for
today's event
this educational web seminar is
sponsored by bio
rad laboratories now i want to invite
everyone to participate by submitting
your questions during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box
located on the far left of your screen
and click send
any questions we do not have time for
during the presentation
will be captured and responded through
the q a list
that will be posted next week in the
event resources box
which is located at the ask a question
box if you have any trouble
technical trouble seeing or hearing this
presentation
simply contact us through the ask a
question box and we will address your
issue
as a reminder this presentation is
educational and offers free pace
continuing education credits
click on the continuing education
credits tab located in the top right
hand corner
of your presentation window and follow
the presentation instructions to obtain
those credits
now let's get started i now present
today's speaker dr
adam lauring dr adam loring is an
associate professor in the department of
internal medicine
division of infectious diseases in the
department of microbiology and
immunology at the university of michigan
he received his undergraduate degree
from yale university
and his md and doctorate from the
university of washington
in seattle dr loring pursued his
postgraduate clinical and research
training at the university of california
san francisco where he completed
medical residency an infectious disease
fellowship
and a post-doctoral fellowship in
biology
he also served as a chief medical
resident in a department of medicine
and he has been on the faculty at the
university of michigan since
2012. dr loring studied the fundamentals
of how
viruses mutate and how this drives the
evolution of poliovirus and influenza
virus
his more recent work utilizes advanced
sequencing of
patient samples to define how viruses
transmit
in households and escape host immunity
he's using similar approaches to
understand how sars cov2
evolves within the host and spreads
between them
dr laurie is a fellow of the infectious
disease society of america and a member
of the governing council of american
society of virology his research on
respiratory viruses has been
funded by grants from the nih cdc
and the burrows welcome fund and the
bill of melinda
and gates foundation dr luring welcome
sir
you may now begin your presentation
well thank you it's nice to be with you
today i'm going to tell you uh about
sars cov2 variants and what they mean in
terms of diagnostics
as well as uh treatment
and vaccination
first my disclosures
and so the objectives for this webinar
are to distinguish between stars cov2
variants of concern and variants of
interest
to identify varying attributes that
could affect diagnostic testing
and how you can quality control
diagnostic testing
and to summarize the latest data on uh
the most notable stars cov2 variants
and vaccine efficacy
so to start off i think there's uh
naturally a lot of confusion
uh when people talk about sars cookie
two variants
um this is just a a clip from the new
york times
uh where uh eric topol and others uh
push back and we're saying that there's
just too much talk about scary ants and
that there's a lot of discussion about
this variant or that variant um and what
they may mean
but that often leads to a lot of
confusion
so my task today is to
try to clear some of that up because
there are certain things about the
variants that are actually quite
important
as i indicated both for diagnostics and
for how soros cov2 is managed and
prevented so today i'm going to tell you
a little bit about
terminology and some definitions uh go
through some of the key variants of
concern
that many of you have probably heard
about in the news
talk about diagnostics um and how
variants are detected either by
sequencing
or by qpcr methods uh and then
uh i'll conclude by talking about how
variants affect a treatment with
monopoly antibodies
as well as how well the current vaccines
work
against the most notable variants
so first some terminology a mutation
is an actual change in the nucleic acid
or the amino acid sequence
in this case of the virus so we often
talk about specific mutations or mutants
uh notable ones would be these two that
are in the spike protein
called n501y and e484k which i'll
elaborate on in a bit
and then we also hear a lot about
variants and these are a variant is
essentially just
two sequences that are different um
importantly variants can have multiple
mutations
that distinguish them for example the
b117 variant which we've heard a lot
about
actually has 17 characteristic mutations
bender's lineage is often used
that is essentially a variant and its
descendants
so b117 was initially described as a
lineage it was
a group of viruses that ultimately arose
one from one virus but then
it's sort of a family of that virus and
its descendants
uh as in a phylogenetic tree or um
by analogy of family tree a strain
is technically a variant that is
phenotypically different so it's not
just different at its sequence level it
actually behaves
differently uh from a biological
perspective in terms of
whether it causes a different disease
or affects our therapies there was a lot
of discussion early on on what's a
strain and what's a variant
my view is this is basically a garbage
term these days because they're
essentially used interchangeably
so uh there's a classification of
variants of concern or voc variants of
interest
voi or variance under investigation vui
uh the who and the cdc
will classify variants as variants of
concern
if they are distinct
and have reasonable evidence for
concerning biological properties and
most don't believe these are whether
they spread faster
whether they cause more severe disease
whether they complicate therapies or
vaccines
and as you can imagine there's varying
levels of varying levels of evidence
here
and so um the variants of interest are
still
important uh it's just there's not as
concerning they should be to all of us
uh this is a screenshot from this
website
outbreak.info which um is
well curated and uh updated uh
i go to it a lot and it has information
on all the variants of concern and
interest as well as their properties
and where they are in the world so this
is the uh
the biggest uh most important variance
of concern
at least currently b117
b1351 d1617.2
and p1 and i'll be going through each of
these
in order
so as i indicated earlier there's
variance of interest
and then there's also mutations of
interest or mutations of concern
so the variance of interest again these
are not variants of concern
that they're classified as variants of
interest our b
1.427429 which is also known as the
california variant
b 1.526 and its cousins
also known as the new york variant b
1.617
uh there's actually several flavors of
this variant
i showed you 617.2 which is a very
concern and these other ones are
variants of interest
and they're generally grouped together
as quote the india variants
and then there's also p2 which is
related to p1
uh uh and it's also uh was first spotted
in brazil
so those are the variants of interest um
that uh you'll be hearing about
and then there's various mutations that
are important
and many of these mutations are shared
across multiple variants
for example e484k is a mutation that
affects how the virus is recognized by
antibodies
and that is present on multiple
variants of concern similarly l452r and
n501y
are on multiple variants so again it
highlights the issues of
what's a mutation what's a variant and
how they overlap which will become
important
when we get to diagnostics
so now i'll tell you a little bit of
about key variants
the first one is lineage b117
which is also known as the uk variant
in general we like to move away from uh
naming variants by places because it
might not be accurate
um and of course many of these variants
are now all all over the world
this was the first variant that really
caught the world's attention
uh it was again spotted in the united
kingdom uh
over the fall it arose as what's called
a long branch
what you need to know is that it had a
lot of mutations when it was first
identified
and there has been speculation and it's
reasonable uh that this virus could have
arisen
within an immunocompromised host because
it accumulated so many mutations when it
was first spotted
it spreads more rapidly uh in fact the
evidence is perhaps strongest for this
variant that it actually
is uh perhaps more transmissible or
contagious because it spreads through
populations quicker
than the other viruses which is
underlies how it came to dominate the
united kingdom
much of europe and of course now the
united states so it's more difficult to
contain
it does not appear to vary uh in terms
of
age groups that it affects although
there was early speculation
along those lines newer data suggests
that it may cause more severe disease
it's hard to as you can imagine it's
hard to do these studies there's lots of
caveats and confounders
but the data is pointing in that
direction
this is just to show data
that came out at the end of december
showing how quickly
this virus spread in multiple areas of
the united kingdom and of course as i
indicated this has been now
recapitulated
in europe and the united states
b1.351 has also been called the south
african variant
it also appears to spread rapidly
although the data are
not as strong i think as for b117 but
it's also perhaps less complete uh
because
uh it arrows in areas of the world where
there hasn't been as much sequencing
or chances in the united kingdom
it's in the u.s and it's currently
staying at a low level thus far
and there's been speculation that it and
other variants really just can't compete
with b117 because b117
spreads so so much better than the
others that
these these other variants of concern
can't get a foothold in the host's
population
there's concern that it's less
neutralizable by serum
by antibodies which i'll get to later in
the talk and that's thought to be
attributable to this e4k mutation which
is in the spike protein
which then causes a change in charge
and they affect how antibodies bind
p1 is another variant of concern it's
also known as the brazilian variant
it was identified when there's in the
fall
again explosive outbreaks in manaus a
state
in brazil and also reports of
reinfection
with this variant it is also spread
fairly quickly
and it also has three mutations that it
shares with beef 1.351
these three mutations in spike are k417t
e484k and n501y
and so these mutations in combination
are what make
both p1 and p1.351 somewhat concerning
next uh in the last few weeks we've been
hearing a lot about
b 1.617 0.2 which is also known as the
indian variant or the double mutant
and it has been coincident with a large
surge in india
it's not clear whether it's driving the
surge or whether
it's just the virus that's been around
in india
and that's because it's relative
transmissibility how how fast it spreads
is not really clear
it has two mutations that have caught uh
people's interest
l 452r which is in the spike
of receptor receptor binding domain and
also
important for antibody recognition and
p681r which is in
the part of the protein that
may have a role in cell entry
and then there's others that uh related
to this that have this e44 q mutation
which is at the same position but a
different mutation
of course than e4k which i indicated are
in the brazilian and south african
variants
and this is just to show you the the
quote california variant 427-429 which
we've heard a lot about in the u.s
and these also share this l 452r
mutation shown at the bottom here um in
the receptor binding vein the receptor
is shown in purple
and so again it's indicating that this
l452r mutation may affect
how the virus recognizes its receptor
and how it might be
neutralized by antibodies and also
highlights how
different variants can share mutations
so how does one identify these variants
uh most commonly they have been
identified through sequencing
or genomic surveillance this is just to
show the workflow that we use in my lab
to identify uh variants and to perform
genomic surveillance
uh in our area we retrieve samples from
our clinical microbiology laboratories
so these are
uh np swabs that are in transport media
and then we extract the rna we then do
a reverse transcription to convert it to
cdna and then a multiplex
pcr using the arctic protocol which is
what most people use
which generates 109 overlapping 400 base
pair
amplicons spanning the entire 30kb
genome
we then perform a library prep for next
generation sequencing
we either use the oxford nanopore
technology
platform shown up top which offers a
quicker turnaround for us about four
days from sample to data
or we've used the alumina platform which
gives a slightly longer turnaround time
but
a higher throughput once we get the data
we do an additional day of analysis
one we multiplex our samples so we
sequence up to 192 samples
um at once with barcodes and then we use
the barcodes
to de-multiplex these to individual
sample sequences
and then we use some available online
tools which are fantastic
one is nexclade which allows you to
identify the mutations in the sequence
data
and offer some quality control metrics
to determine whether your sample quality
is good whether the sequence data is
good etc
we then use pangolin which is another
tool
which uh you feed in the sequence data
and then it
gives you the lineage or the variance so
it'll tell you
this sequence is b1.1.7 this one's
b1.351 etc
it essentially classifies the viruses
based on the signature mutations for
each of the variants
now we spent a fair bit of time in
establishing our sequencing workflows
paying attention to quality control
and this is important because as i
showed on the earlier slide there's a
lot of steps
including reverse transcription and pcr
and then
the actual sequencing where you can get
errors introduced
and not true mutations but false
positive mutations
this can occur either at the consensus
level so the main sequence
of the sample or when you're looking for
rare mutations within
a given sample like many viruses stars
cov2
individuals will have additional
mutations that arise
after they're infected these won't these
will be a low frequency often at five or
ten percent
and you can sometimes detect these into
sequence data
but again it's important that attention
is paid to quality control
the way we've done this is we've used
defined rna templates and
mix them and so we we can start with a
an rna
that corresponds to the luhan
stranosaurus cov2 or and an rna that
corresponds to a different sars kobe 2
sequence
and then we will mix these together so
you can get
90 percent 10 or 80 20
mixtures and then also dilute how much
of our
input there is to get a sense of
sensitivity
so we'll mix those to rt pcr and
sequence just as i indicated before for
a real sample
and what we'll do is we'll look in our
data for these
individual mutations that differ between
the two strains
so if we do an 80 20 mix we'll say okay
well we should see
these seven mutations in this lower
strain
at eighty percent frequency uh and uh
we'll see twenty percent of the other
and then
also we can then see how sensitive and
specific
our sequencing and analysis is for
detecting specific mutations
uh in mixtures and also at varying
inputs
and so what the data has looked like for
us uh is shown here and the first series
of four plots
we're looking at sensitivity so how good
are we at detecting mutations
um at these frequencies uh at the x axis
so 0 5 10 15
and i indicated there's seven mutations
so you can see
at each frequency how how many of those
seven we identify
and then the four quadrants represent
four different inputs
of a template so it gets you a sense of
if you have a low input sample so
someone who
has a high ct value on their qpcr
testing how good are you at finding
mutations
in that sample then we also use these
data to look at our false positive rate
so how many times do you identify a
mutation that's not actually in there
because again because we have defined
templates that we use in these studies
so that we could see
if there's a mutation that we find in
our data that's not there
that's a false positive what we find is
we often have a lot of false positives
when there's very low input samples so
this with this one with 100 false
positives
is a sample that had 100 copies of rna
in it
and so that's not very much and that the
number of false positive reflects that
you go through a lot of rt pcr cycles
where errors are introduced
when you have lower input sample
and so that is a good way of using uh
defined templates to quality control
your sequencing and have confidence in
your data so that you can then move
forward to
actually identify variants
there's also been a proliferation in
recent weeks and months of non-sequence
diagnostics for variants
of course with sequencing you can find
whatever is out there
it's unbiased but sequencing diagnostics
you can find
things that you're specifically looking
for
which and also with less cost
and a more rapid turnaround this became
prominent
with b117 uh b117 has a characteristic
deletion
in its uh spike protein gene uh and
thermo fisher
tac path assay uh has an interesting
pattern called sgtf
when on that b117 variant so the tacpath
assay has three different probes
uh sets that recognize n or 1ab
and spike gene sequences
b117 has this deletion and so you don't
detect
the s probe so you'll get positive
detection on these other two but you'll
have what's called
s gene target failure or sgtf
and this has been a useful surrogate for
b117
in tracking its frequency
in regions of the u.s as is shown here
on this graphic
from cdc looking at sgtf and non-sjts
samples over time
the important thing to realize is that
there are other variants that also have
this deletion
and so there's been non-b117 in the us
that also will give you
sgtf and it's just important to realize
that this is a surrogate marker so it's
not always
a diagnostic of a given variant because
these mutations can occur in multiple
variants
this is a useful website if you just
google fda guidance
and viral mutations and tests you can
find it
it'll it it has up-to-date information
on
molecular tests and how they're impacted
by stars cov2 mutations
and then of course now there's a more
commercially available
primer probe sets to detect specific
mutations
and as i indicated of course mutations
can be found in multiple variants so
here's
a pro a primer uh probe set that would
recognize
n501y uh uh
and on this graphic and you can see that
it's found in
various lineages at varying frequencies
so
it's uh not entirely specific for a
given variant but as
useful as a marker similarly e4k
is in many different lineages now and
many different variants
and so it's a good marker and it's a
good probe to use but it's not entirely
specific
and so for example if you want to detect
b117
people will actually use this nd3l
mutation because it's only really
present
in b117 so it's a reliable marker
for that lineage
and then of course quality control in
these pcr assays
is also important because uh you're
often dealing in surveillance
uh with something that might be rare at
first and so if something is rare
or low prevalence your assay has to be
extremely
sensitive and specific uh to have a
good predictive value something i'm sure
many of you are familiar with
um in diagnostics and this just again is
a reminder that if you
have some a variant that might be a 10
or 20 percent prevalence
even with the 90 sensitive and specific
assay
you're still uh basically at 50 to 70
predicted value um and so it just really
highlights that even minor decrements
incentive sensitivity and specificity
can really diminish the utility of an
assay that's not
well quality controlled
so key points in evaluating diagnostics
are
to determine the analytic sensitivity
and specificity
uh and qpcr assays this would uh
be how well you can discriminate between
alternate alleles so
how well you discriminate 501y from 501n
at the n501 mutation how do you
determine the cutoff ct
or your limit of detection um and then
in all these things synthetic materials
like these rna templates or
are often more readily available than
clinical specimens
particularly for newly arising variants
and
they are more easily adapted to a
quantitative readout
and that you know exactly how many
copies
there are in your
template for quality controlling these
assets
and then also high accuracy is necessary
when
mutations or variants are rare and then
matching mutations to the actual variant
is important in evaluating the
diagnostic utility
so i'll spend the next few minutes i'm
talking about
the clinical impact of these variants
one is looking at monoclonal antibodies
so there's three different
monoclonals currently that have fda
emergency youth emergency use
authorization
uh for a treatment of individuals
infected with sarcoid ii
um this is quite a complicated process
because
the they are only really effective when
they're given very early an infection
and so uh there's again three one is
catarisma
plus independent that's called the
regeneron cocktail
there's bam rene or bam which
is a eli lilly monoclonal and then eli
lilly now also has a cocktail
bamboo bamla nivamab and etazivimab
uh together and then the good thing
about these cocktails is they have two
monofilaments that
recognize different uh parts of the
spike protein and so they
are more likely to retain neutralization
activity
uh even in the presence of a specific
mutation
and these are tables are from the eua
fact sheets uh from the fda you can find
it on their website
uh and it shows for the different
variants
the key substitutions in them and what
that does how well
the antibodies recognize them so you can
see that the casarivamab and devinmav
cocktail
works well against many of the most
common variants
whereas e484k or l452r
really make it so that bamlinevamav
doesn't work very well
against those viruses
and so a patient who has one of these
variants who's treated with this
antibody
may have less
less of a response or get less benefit
so however if you have the cocktail
of bam plus edazimab you retain activity
against many of these variants
so at our center we my laboratory has
been doing a lot of sequencing
and we provide a weekly
report on the frequency of given
mutations and variants
in our patient population and this is
just one of them
showing the frequency of n501y here in
green
which is a marker or a mutation on b117
and this is when b117 really surged in
michigan
but then uh lower down you can see the
red line which shows l452r
and its frequency over time and e484k
in yellow and what we do is we work with
our antimicrobial stewardship team
these are just two tweets from jason
pogue from our group
and we track these mutations and once
we're at a specific
frequency will alter what we use as our
empiric therapy for monoclonal so if we
see a lot of l452r and e44k
we might switch to the either the eli
lily or the regeneron combinations
as our empiric therapy so this is just
one way of using
uh surveillance data on viruses in a
community
to help choose empiric therapy
even if you can on an individual level
get the
identification of the variant quick
enough uh
to affect uh antibody choice you can do
so
uh at a more population level
so what about vaccines and so this is a
headline from a new york article
early in january when
uh there was a lot of buzz about
variants and vaccines and concern
that the vaccines of the variants may
invade the vaccine
and since there's since then there's
been a torrent of data
on this that i'll attempt to summarize
in just a few minutes
so again spike is the major antigen that
we're talking about here is
a protein that sits on the surface of
the virus it mediates
uh receptor binding and entry into cells
uh
shown in the red picture but it's also
recognized by
uh the antibodies um and that if an
antibody binds
on the spike protein they'll neutralize
virus and then the virus can't bind
receptors so
they would be protective
there's been a lot of data a lot of
studies
looking at how well someone's antibodies
recognize
different variants so of course
the vaccines that are in use uniformly
use
a spike protein from what might be
considered the original or ancestral
stars cody2
that was around in spring 2020 now the
the
despite variants are different and so
people have taken
sera from people whose immune systems
have been stimulated by this
original variant in this case wa1
washington one shown in gray
and then c compare how well those serum
recognize
other variants and here showing b117 p1
and v1.35
this is just from um a couple studies
that are representative and some of the
first
and looking at how well uh these sierra
from vaccinated individuals recognize
spikes and you can see that
b117 appears to be well recognized um by
post-vaccination sera even though
there's a dramatically different spike
protein so it's not
terribly different energetically from
wa1 however p1 and b1.351
are a little bit different and p1
appears to be
nearly as well recognized as the other
variant
v117 and the original um but b
1.351 there does appear to be a drop-off
it's about three to four-fold in most
studies uh and so
there's a drop-off but what we don't
know is does that translate to not being
protected
then um here's a similar data
from another study looking at b1.351
b1.429 which is one of the california
variants
um and then looking at a range of
vaccines so this would be
convalescent serum from people who
recovered the modern
cirrus from people from the modern
vaccine or
syria from people who got the novobax
subunit vaccine
and you can see that with 1.429 there's
a slight decrease
um similar to p1 perhaps and then b
1.351
has a several fold approximately
five-fold decrease
in neutralizing activity
so it appears that b1.351 and
particularly
is energetically different that if you
stimulate your immune system by
vaccination with the original
as far as cov2 those antibodies aren't
quite as good at recognizing
b1.351 the big question is how does this
affect protection because we don't know
what titer
is really protective this is data from a
animal study with monkeys looking to try
to define that threshold and so
you have an antibody a titer of
approximately 40
is protective of macaques from infection
that means you can dilute someone sarah
40 fold
and still uh show that that
zero would still be protective and so
that helps place some of this in context
i'll just go back to an earlier slide
so we see that with b1.351
you get a drop in your sensitivity shown
in this
plot here to neutralization
and the question is does it are you
still protected are you still above this
threshold which is
uh at this dashed line of 1 to 40.
and so that's reassuring that many
people will still be protected
even if they uh are presented with b
1.351
but this is an area of active
investigation and we still don't really
know for sure
so moving ahead it just highlights that
looking at sierra can give you some sort
of idea of how well
a vaccine may work but it's not
everything
and shown here are a set of titers
um which are actually my antibody titers
against different flu strains
and so you can see that um i have quite
good titers against the vaccines which
are the egg-based flu
at one to twenty five sixty you can
dilute my sero25
to over two thousand fold and it'll
still neutralize these viruses
however it's not quite as good against
uh
these actually circulating viruses which
are labeled as cell
and does that mean i'm not protected
well
i probably do have some level of
protection because i actually haven't
gotten symptomatic with flu
in the past 10 years and that just
really highlights that the serology is
only part of the story
and so and it's also that vaccines don't
really work as a plus minus
that it's also does it protect you from
severe disease
mild disease does it prevent
transmission
what are the population effects and it
really gets complicated
so what do the actual studies show
because the best way to show whether a
variant
isn't whether vaccine doesn't work
against bavarian is to see if the
vaccine doesn't work against the variant
and the data now are accumulating
here's a slide that i try to routinely
update as as papers come in
i'm looking at some of the data from the
randomized trials
and so and some of the observational
studies as well
so the jansen or jnj vaccine in the fda
filing which is now
published as a peer-reviewed article
it was 72 percent effective in the
united states
uh it retained a fair bit of that
efficacy
in brazil where the p1 and p2 variants
were circulating it was 68
effective and there was also an arm of
the trial
excuse me in south africa where it
proved to be 64
effective um and that many of the cases
uh
uh in the vaccinated arm of the study
were due to
be 1.351 is pfizer
uh mrna vaccine um uh
that trial had an arm that was uh
performed in
the united kingdom at the time that v117
was becoming
uh prevalent and there's also been
the siren study which is an
observational study
um in the united kingdom at that time
the siren study showed that it was 85
percent
effective in uh protecting um
against uh infection which was uh
presumably when b117 was uh prevalent in
the united kingdom
and then novavax uh had a similar
uh its study was going on in the united
kingdom when b117 is around and it was
quite effective
um and then it had some drop-off
and efficacy against the 1.351
from the study arm in south africa
um and so there's there's almost every
week there's new data
um on how well the vaccines work against
these variants it seems that b117
there's going to be retained vaccine
effectiveness
but there might be a small drop off in
protection from b1.351
potentially p1 but these vaccines still
prevent severe disease
from these variants as well
and that kind of charts the way forward
uh much like in
influenza uh there will be surveillance
every year
to look at how different variants
that might be around um
affect how the vaccines work and so you
can do this by looking at people who are
vaccinated
and still get infected and try to see if
the variants are more common
in those individuals which might suggest
that they are evading the vaccine
protection and this is just one
case report in new england journal
looking at a breakthrough infection
um the challenge here is sometimes these
numbers are small so this
this report looked at two people who had
breakthrough infections
but to really understand how these viral
sequences relate to breakthrough
uh infections and vaccinated individuals
you really need large numbers and so
those studies are ongoing and i suspect
within the next year we'll have a lot
more information
on how variants are affecting vaccines
and so i'll conclude by thanking you for
your attention
and look forward to discussing this
further in the q a
thank you
so let's begin thank you dr luring for
that informative presentation
we will now start the q a portion of the
webinar and if you have any questions
you want to ask audience members please
do so now
just click on that ask a question box
located on the far
left of your screen so let's get started
it looks like we already have some great
questions coming in
from our audience dr lauren
how closely should labs be monitoring
the proliferation of variants in their
populations sure
uh you know i think it's going to be
important moving forward that
um clinical micro laboratories
um you know keep updated um
on you know not only what's going on
nationally but what's going on
regionally
in their catchment areas because as
we've seen that
you know there's there's gonna be new
variants coming and it's important to
be aware of it uh and of course be ahead
of the game
uh in terms of you know any measures
that need to be doing
to either update the assays or know how
your various testing platforms are going
to perform
um you know in the setting of a new
variant
so i think it it will continue to be
important at least for this
foreseeable future thank you so much and
that brings us to this next great
question from one of our audience
members
what action should be taken to help
challenge our assays to make sure they
are detecting
existing and any new mutations
sure i think uh i mean one thing is as i
indicated in my talk
you know the fda is continually updating
um on their website uh as as
data come in on how various uh you know
approved or eua
you know diagnostics are affected by uh
a variance
uh but i think you know labs will
certainly have a need to test
their assays against new variants as
they arise
either you know by having sam you know
actual
you know available residual clinical
samples
that correspond to given variance or by
uh
perhaps your quality controlling their
assays on
your defined templates or rnas that
you have the same sequence as these
variants just to ensure that the assays
are
you know still performing uh uh you know
as expected
uh in terms of you know diagnosing uh
as far as kobe 2 in someone who may have
a different variant
thank you so much and again i want to
thank our audience for these great
questions coming in
our next question aside from the public
health value
is there a clinical role for
distinguishing
sgtf from non-sgtf
variants sure um
i think the main clinical role uh would
be
uh in terms of of therapeutics
i mean even the vaccines i i would
consider that kind of half clinical have
public health because
um you know often you would be dealing
with someone who's vaccinated and it's
of interest to know
if they have a variant you know and
that's why the vaccine may not have
worked
but in terms of direct clinical utility
i think it's therapeutics and
and the area where it's become most
important
as i indicated in the talk is with you
know antibody therapy where
that can uh make a difference and so
uh i think that's gonna be a key area
we don't really have a lot of
information on uh
variants and other therapeutics um but
that certainly is something that could
play out in the future
uh you know whether certain variants you
know
as we've seen with other viruses are
less uh sensitive to
rendezvous or other antivirals that come
down the pike
that will become important as well and
then uh as a clinician i can tell you
that
even if it's not clinically important
your clinicians will be asking you
um uh asking the clinical lab you know
is this
you know variant x um is that why this
patient
you know is not doing well even if even
if it's not
really usable in that way you'll find
your clinicians are going to want
to know um and then the last thing is uh
in the clinical realm but also public
health is we found that
knowing variant status is of some use to
our infection control and prevention
uh by teams and not in our health system
uh in terms of making sure that they're
doing everything they can to
limit the spread of stars could be two
and encoded
in uh healthcare settings
thank you so much now do you see the
need for developing
variant assays and submit for
eua um i you know i think there
i think there certainly is a role for it
uh you know
obviously i'm not a regulatory uh
specialist
um but you know i think uh you can
certainly see
uh particularly if we find more and more
that these variants can affect
um you know clinical uh decision making
uh that you know having a you know eua
you know for you know detection of a
specific
specific variant would be important um
so that you know that
you know has a layer of uh compliance
and regulatory so that you can
you know use that data um and uh
you know make decisions based on it so i
i i do think there's a role how
expansive that role is it's going to be
it's hard for me to say right now but i
do think it's important
thank you so much now what role will
pcr assay's detecting mutations will
have particularly in
complement to sequencing
sure i mean i think uh the you can see
it playing out
kind of two different ways and i do
think phrasing it as complementary
is really key uh of course uh
you know sequencing is unbiased right
it's gonna detect what's out there
um uh whereas uh you know pcr is a
you know much more scalable and
directed way um for specific variants
so i think you know both are going to be
hand in hand
you know i think once a variant is in an
area at a certain frequency
you know i think pcr uh is is going to
be the way to go and you know
we've certainly seen this uh with uh
b117 which was first identified
you know and tracked um from sequencing
and then it was realized that it had
this unique signature
um with the tac path assay as i
highlighted in the talk and so
then that became a nice surrogate um uh
you know to really know very quickly who
would have that
variant and how it might be you use that
information moving forward so
i think they work hand in hand
thank you so much and we have a final
question from our audience members
they say great talk covered in detail
about the impact of the mutations on the
vaccines
how are the mutations impacting the
diagnostics any thoughts on how best we
can
quantify that impact
so um if i'm understanding the question
is you know how
can we measure how much you know either
one variant
or any number of variants are affecting
uh our ability to diagnose sars kobe 2.
um i must say i haven't
seen much evidence that you're getting
in a significant manner like complete
assay failure that your assays are not
detecting uh and i've seen a few reports
here and there
uh but in terms of the prominent
variants uh
you know most of most if not all of the
diagnostic platforms will still
um give you a diagnosis um
that you know even the tagpath assay
which has this you know signature
of the s gene target failure um the
other there's two other targets
uh and those um are picking it up well
so
i'm not aware of uh any of the variants
yet
having a significant impact on on just
overall diagnostics
dr lauren thank you for your
presentation today would you like to
provide any closing remarks to our
audience before we go
no i think uh i think it's it's an
exciting area and
it's something to continually watch um
because it's really an area where i
think
clinical diagnostics are going to be
potentially rapidly changing over the
next year or two
and thank you again for your time today
and for your important research
before we go i want to thank our
audience members
for joining us today and for their
important questions questions we did not
have time for today
will be answered and posted in the event
resources
by june 4th and this webcast will be
available
for on-demand in the auditorium from
thursday on
if you found this information
informative
and helpful please share it with your
colleagues
and for the next webinar on june 30th we
will have dr
lauren bachmann from virginia
commonwealth university
medical center presenting on best
practices to recover from an
out of control event please stay tuned
and watch your email
inbox for that invitation until next
time everyone stay safe and stay healthy
take care
bye